- Hello believe nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe.
and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all the
major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn seven ways
to overcome bad situations.
And as always guys as you're listening,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down the comments below.
Put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself too.
Enjoy.
- [Electronic Voice] Nine, eight.
- So, being an entrepreneur is tough.
It's one of the hardest things
you're ever going to do in your life.
If you think it's going to be easy,
you're in for a world of pain.
And so overcoming bad situations
is going to be part of the game.
It's something that you're going to deal
with on a consistent basis.
And so I'm going to share with you
my seven tips on how you can do it.
Number one is changed your mindset.
And this is a really important one.
It's so easy to get sucked in
and lost in negativity
that you just stay there
and spiral out of control.
And you as an entrepreneur,
you're the leader.
There's nobody above you saying hey,
come on let's do this go, go, go.
That's on you.
And especially if you have your team,
you can't get stuck in a bad place
because you're going to
bring all your team down
and they won't be productive either.
And so start by changing your mindset.
Look at it as an opportunity to grow,
to get better, to build stronger.
Anytime there's something major
that happens in my business,
it sucks, but immediately I start to think
okay how can I make this better?
How do I solve this problem?
How do I see this as an opportunity?
How is this going to
make my business better
for the long term?
And as soon as you can
break out of the immediacy
of the negativity and start
looking at how do I fix this,
how do I solve this, how do I get better,
how do I make this stronger?
As soon as you start asking
those kinds of questions,
it pulls you into positivity
and it pulls you into the
most important part of all:
action, fixing the problem
and actually doing something about it.
Change your mindset.
Tip number two is remember your why.
This is why it's so important
to have a strong why
when you're starting your business.
If you're just starting the business
because you're trying to make money,
you're just reaching
some kind of opportunity,
this is where you're going to quit.
As soon as you start facing
multiple bad situations
over and over and repeated again,
you're going to quit
because you thought it was easy money,
you thought it was passive income,
and so that's why you got into it.
It gets hard; you're going to bail
and go somewhere else.
If you have a deep passion for it though,
you have a strong why as
why you are doing this,
why it's important.
This is going to get done.
Remembering that helps push you through
the crap that you have to deal with.
There's a great interview with Steve Jobs
where he's talking about
you have to kind of be crazy
as an entrepreneur.
You have to be crazy
in love with your idea
because running the business
and starting it is so hard
that any sane logical person would quit
because you're sane, because your normal,
because your logical, because
it's just way too hard.
Nobody wants to deal with all this crap,
but the thing that gets you through
is that strong why,
that insane passion for what you're doing.
And so whenever you're down in the hole,
think back to why you
started this business,
why it's so important to you.
You better have a reason other than money,
otherwise you're in trouble.
Tip number three is model success.
Whenever you don't know what to do,
model a success I find
is one of the best single strategies
that you can do to help
you get out of your hole.
And so find somebody who's been in
that same situation as you have,
and how did they overcome it?
And I find two great things happen
when you model success
and read their stories
of famous entrepreneurs
who have come before you.
One is you get the tactical
things of what to do.
Like okay Oprah Winfrey went through this
and here's how she came through.
Or Steve Jobs went through this
and here's how he came through.
Or Bill Gates had this happen
And you get the tactics the specific steps
of what to do that they did.
Second thing, though that
I think is really important
is just the motivation.
Just knowing, at least for me,
knowing that these people struggled
and suffered early on in their careers
makes me feel like I'm not alone.
Made me feel like if they could do it.
I could do it too.
And, so I would always
start my day reading
a story of a famous entrepreneur
and how they got started.
Now we use the top ten because it's video
and I much prefer video,
but being able to watch somebody's story,
hear from their advice,
gave me both the motivation to keep going,
as well as the tactics on what to do.
And so whenever you're in the hole,
at least I found that to be super helpful
to help me get out.
Model success.
- Tip number four is to
focus on a teachable lesson.
So I had a situation where
I had a really close
friend of mine betray me
in the worst way possible.
She stole something very important to me
that was really near and dear to my heart.
And I focused on the negative.
I focused on the bad
situation that happened
and I carried that
resentment everywhere I went.
I'm not an angry person at all,
but I was punching holes through walls.
I was hurting myself.
I was angry at everything around me
and I was so resentful
and angry everywhere I went.
It affected my relationships.
It affected my friendships.
It affected the way I operated at work.
And I needed to find a solution.
So the solution was to focus
on the teachable lesson.
What can I learn from this?
I had to learn how to forgive.
Resentment wouldn't take me anywhere.
Anger wouldn't take me anywhere,
but forgiveness can.
So every single day I worked
on forgiving this person.
I had to let her go.
Even though I haven't seen her again,
I no longer hold the need to seek revenge
to see her suffer because
she made me suffer so badly.
I wish her all the happiness in the world
and I hope she's doing well.
So the next time you find
yourself in a bad situation,
always try to remember
the teachable lesson
and think to yourself what
can I learn from this?
- Tip number five is find another way.
And so this again is why
the why is so important.
You know, you're down in the hole.
You're struggling.
You're sucking.
You've got no energy left.
Thinking to yourself what
I have done is not working,
but there is another way to go.
This is what I use really effectively
in my first business.
When I told my partner that I quit,
when I felt so worthless and useless
and I had no value,
I felt like I wasn't bringing
anything to this business
and I just felt so low I myself,
I woke up the next day after
telling my partner that I quit
and I said I have to find another way.
There has to be another way.
Someway to solved this.
It's not that the whole idea sucks.
Just the way we've been
doing it has sucked
and there's another path.
There's another way to stay
and I've just got to find that.
And it actually ended up being a blessing
because good is the enemy of great.
If what I was doing was kind of working,
I might have just stuck
with doing what was kind of working,
but knowing that it wasn't working at all
meant that I had to find
a totally different path.
I had to find a totally new innovative way
to market and improve my business.
And it ended up being my model of success
by going through partnerships
by looking at what Bill
Gates did to build Microsoft
through partnerships and applying that
to my company and that's
when we started to
get a lift.
But just that mindset that
this isn't total failure
what's happening right now.
Just the way that I've been doing it,
hasn't been working
and I need to find another way.
Tip number six is just go back to work.
Sometimes the best thing you can do
is just get back to work
and start building something.
When you start taking action
good things start to happen.
When you are just negative and sad
and down what ends up happening?
You don't do anything.
You sit there and you wallow
and you stay in your head
and you get frustrated and you complain.
And the solution out
sometimes is just do the work.
There was this interview
I was watching recently
of Joe Rogan.
We're doing a top ten volume two on him.
He was saying that if he waited
until he was super motivated and excited
to go out and go work out,
he would never work out.
He'd be this fat slob
because he never feels
motivated to work out.
He forces himself to
just go out and do it.
And so having a schedule
I find really helps me.
Knowing what I'm doing
every day really helps me.
Yes there are some days that I'm inspired
and motivated and excited.
I want to do brand new things.
And when that happens,
sometimes I'll throw away my schedule
and just go all in on this new idea
because gold's going to come out of it.
But on the days when I wake up
and I'm not super excited and motivated
and pumped ready to go you know
I have my calendars.
Like this is what I'm going to do today.
I have a schedule.
I know what's going to happen.
And if I grind out that work today,
good things are going to happen.
I'm going to get closer
to achieving my goals.
And so sometimes the way
out of a bad situation
is just going back to work.
And my number seven tip is remember
that somebody has it worse.
Both from a global perspective,
you know the fact that you
are watching this video,
you have access to the internet,
you invest in yourself
and personal development
and watching these you know video content
to help you get better and improve.
Just the fact that you are here
puts you ahead of most
people in the world, right?
And so the problems that you're facing
are not actually that big compared to
what most people in the
world have to deal with.
That sometimes could help.
The other thing that
really helps me though
is also remembering that
a lot of people that I
look up to the people
that I aspire to be like
in terms of the impact
that they're having,
people have done things amazing things
with fewer resources
than you have right now.
The people that you look up to people
who have gone on and done just amazing,
mind-blowing things inside
and outside your industry.
Your role models.
Look back to how they started.
Chances are they started with less
than what you already have right now.
And so remembering that
and that they were able to rise up
and do such amazing things
and the forced creativity
that had to come from it
because they didn't
have a lot of resources
when they were starting their business
that always turns into motivation for me
and pulls me through bad times.
So those are my seven tips
on how to overcome bad situations.
I'd love to know which
one did you resonate
the most with and why.
Is there an eight, nine, 10
that you want to add to the list
that maybe I missed?
leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I made this video because a Amervin Bonano
asked me to.
So if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in a future seven ways video,
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Christi Vlad.
Christi, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book: You're One Word
and making that YouTube
video on it as a review.
I really really appreciate support
and I'm so glad that you love the book.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.